yeah so i spent like 90 minutes on this
book and it's a online fix
hello happy friday evening
we are in downtown carlsbad
taking a stroll right along the beach
that's the ocean taking a little family
[Music]
walk
[Music]
this is it this is why we moved to san
diego
so we could go to the beach in 10
minutes like this
damn it's pretty it's so pretty
people are swimming in the ocean
it's 1204 am
scott and i are trying to debug an issue
in
the app that i've been working on weekly
which is a um
shopping list app on ios using swift ui
and i have a crash right now and i just
don't know
how to fix it luckily i made like a
little playground
over here this is my little like
sample playground that like is like a
much simpler
version of what i'm trying to do right
now
i'm working on paring down my current
code you see all that stuff that's
commented out paring it down to see if
it'll like
have the same behavior but it's not and
i feel i haven't felt this way scott
since like
college programming assignments i just
have like
no clue what's going on and i feel like
my brain is melding together with the
code
my brain is melting i brought scott and
for reinforcements because
i needed it but it's hard what if
tomorrow we wake up and then we're just
like
oh no duh we're missing an at sign or
something it's not what's wrong
you think so yeah my brain's starting to
get delirious
and you got this i'm gonna
quit and restart xcode
maybe that'll do it you know okay okay
syntax
syntax highlighting is back baby
if this works just because i had to quit
and restart xcode and remove all the
cast info
i will just nope still crashing
[Music]
oh i got it to crash oh
oh you're embedding it in a sheet
what the [ __ ] is that supposed to be
here
what if and at the end all i do is just
file a bug to apple and i'm like in this
really specific case by the way
your breaks oh
i think someone has the same issues
are you
i may have just figured it out
okay okay baby we're getting somewhere
we are getting
somewhere let's see if this is gonna
crash y'all
ready for this look at how bare bones i
made that view
it's so bare bones already usually when
i click this this is when it crashes
huh
it's god it'll work
i think i got it
oh my god
why yes i spent like 90 minutes on this
book
and it's a one-line fix
it's the moment of truth
it works just remember kids
folks people out there behind every
stock overflow
question is probably like five hours of
banging your head on the desk
trying to figure out what went wrong so
be kind to one another when you're
helping each other online
because my brain is so fried
good night everybody i'm tired
good morning everybody it's tuesday
it's like a little before 11 a.m
and uh yeah we're like done unpacking
um i thought i would show you a little
bit of a house tour obviously
nothing is done things are messy but
uh it's probably gonna stay this way for
a while because it's gonna take us a
long time to decorate everything
but i figured i'd show you maybe like
like a kind of before
shot of what our house is and then maybe
like
many months down the line i'll show you
a after of how it turned out
also this is not going to be like
aesthetic or like
there's a lot of parts in my house that
are not clean
but you know what i don't care this is
real life you all want to see behind the
scenes
you're all going to get the behind the
scenes that are very
realistic and not like scrubbed or
cleaned
or anything at all maybe it'll make me
look a little bit sloppy but it's not
anything super terrible and i'm willing
to live with my mess on the internet
just a little bit you know
so this is our formal dining room uh we
bought
that table from craigslist recently but
i'm gonna refinish it you know with my
new woodworking skills
um so it's just kind of sitting there
right now and then there's all the rest
of this
random stuff but that's the dining room
and then we go over here and this is the
formal living room which doesn't have
like
any furniture um i gotta buy couches for
this area
and then over there is a little proof of
concept
of uh how we want to set up like a
little
tea area over here we've got a wet bar
we're gonna make this a little bit more
modern too at some point
a little tiny renovation project but
right now it's just got
a bunch of coffee stuff all of scott's
coffee stuff is here so it's more of a
coffee station than it is a wet bar
over here we've got our breakfast nook
which is our main dining area
i went to ikea yesterday so there's like
a bunch of stuff there
told you there was going to be some mess
and then this is our
kitchen which is also kind of a mess but
i like the layout it's a little bit
dated so we're probably going to update
this too at some point
but i quite like it um there's just a
couple of tweaks that i think we'd make
to it
over here we've got our family room uh
which is nice that we have one
i like that we have a separate family
room which is the tv
that's different from the living room
where we can just sit and not watch tv
but most of our furniture from our
living room from our other places here
so this is like one of the very few
complete rooms that we've got
and then check out these sconces i like
to say they're very like
las vegas 90s hotel type
so you know we'll probably replace them
too next up we've got our
master bedroom also kind of a mess
over there is a little bench thing that
i'm gonna like put like couch cushions
on
which will be nice window seating this
is scott's office room
hi scott hi i'm giving people a house
tour
it's really just only got his computer
in here
not the final setup i moved everything
because i'm working on that
yeah none of this is the final setup i
don't think
but it's a livable setup and that's what
we were going for one month into our
move
right bye
[Music]
this is my office room i filmed videos
right there if you can tell
from this couch i've also got like a
little bench seat
and then my desk some storage
and a big ass mirror
these mirrors are so big and then lastly
we've got our guest room which is nice
that we have a separate guest room
without needing to change
our office room um bought that on
craigslist
gonna touch that up as well but i really
like the look of it
and then we got this bed yesterday from
ikea
i'm actually gonna put this which is a
mattress
onto this bed uh which will kind of make
this room feel a little bit more
complete
[Music]
so it's a few hours later and it's all
done it's all done it looks so
good so i've talked about this a bunch
on social media
on twitch instagram on this channel but
sleep is like
so incredibly important to my health
it's the one thing that like completely
improves my mental health my emotional
health and my physical health
so we're actually going to use this bed
as a guest bed which is perfect because
my brother's coming this week
and i'll also be taking naps on this um
but yeah sleep is something that's super
duper important to me and so it was
really important
to find a really good mattress which is
why i'm excited to partner with helix
for this video
so they made this mattress and one of
the cool things about their service is
that they have a sleep quiz that you can
take
to find out which of their mattresses is
perfect for you i'm a back sleeper
myself
and i also tend to like medium firm
mattresses
and i also share the bed with scott and
so it was actually really cool to take
the quiz to find a mattress that's going
to work for me
scott and like most of our guests were
going to be here so
we were matched with the luxe queen
mattress uh it's super easy to order
online
it gets delivered straight to your door
and then you just
unwrap it and open it and let it do its
thing and then now
we have a full bed the shipping cost is
free and they also have a 100
night sleep trial so if after three
months you don't like the mattress then
you can send
it back and get a full refund because
i've partnered with them on this video
if you go to helixsleep.com
hello myuco or click the link in the
description box down below
then you'll get up to 200 off of your
mattress and two free pillows
thank you to helix for sponsoring
today's video and i
am ready to take a nap
i don't know